does history repeat itself in which way
does it repeat itself in which way does
it not
i'm afraid it repeats itself a lot um so
i i think human nature kind of is what
it is and so we tend to see similar
behavior patterns emerging again and
again and so
it's it's kind of the
exception rather than the rule when
something new happens
what role does technology play
in the suppression or in revealing human
nature
well the standards of living life
expectancy all that have gotten
incredibly better within the last
particularly the last hundred years i
mean just antibiotics
modern vaccines
electrification
the internet these are all
improvements in most people's standard
of living and health
and longevity that
that exceed anything that was seen
before in in human history
so
so people are living longer they're
generally healthier and so on but again
we still see a lot of the same behavior
patterns some of which are
not very attractive
so some of it has to do with the
constraints on resources presumably with
technology you have less and less
constraints on resources so
we get to maybe emphasize the better
angels of our nature
and in in so doing does that not
potentially
fundamentally alter the sort of
the experience that we have of life on
earth you know until the last 10 or so
years i would have
taken that view i think but
you know
people who will find ways to be
[Music]
to be divisive and angry um
if it scratches a kind of psychological
itch that they have got and um we used
to look at the weimar republic
what happened in the economic collapse
of germany prior to um
the the rise of hitler um world war ii
uh
and kind of uh
explain
hitler at least partially by
um
just the the misery that people were
living in at that time
um the economic collapse yeah
hyperinflation and unemployment and um
the
the decline in standard of living and
that sounds like a plausible uh
explanation but there are economic
troubles now for sure we had the bank
collapse in 2008
and there's stagnation
in some people's standards of living but
it's hard to explain what we've seen in
this country in the last few years just
strictly on the basis of
people are poor and angry and sad
i think they want to be angry
so
without being political in a divisive
kind of way
can we talk about the lessons you can
draw from world war ii
sure this singular event in human
history it seems like yeah and yet as
you say
history rhymes
at the very least yeah being who i am i
tend to focus on the
curious technological things that
happened in in conjunction with that war
um
which may not be where you want to go
but uh well there's several things
inside to interrupt so one in crypto
nomicon is more like the alan turing
side of things right right and then
and then there's the
outside of technology
first of all there's the tools of war
which is the kind of technology
but then there's just like the human
nature the nature of good and evil yeah
well so one of the things that emerges
from
uh from the war and from the um the
extermination camps is that we were
never allowed to have illusions anymore
about human nature
so
you you have to to learn that lesson to
be
an educated person and you have to know
that
that even in a supposedly you know
enlightened civilized society people can
become monsters
quite easily
you